the Iguana got out of the cage and I was
like trying to get it and I was trying
to scoop him but they have like little
talons
and their Skin's weird and they have
like little stomachs and when they
breathe they're like yeah so it's like
you can feel their little bodies
I was like I don't want to hurt you I
was like [__] five I walked in the
[__] was running
and I'm like stopping stopping the fool
tries to go and I go like that I put my
hand on his tail to try to stop it and
it [__] came off and the tail just
went
as I stopped it and I noticed that it
kept running and that's when I noticed
the tail was still under my hand and I
[__] you ever see a Dragon Ball Z
when they go
they [__] power up that was pretty
much me I saw the tail and I went
no I [__] screamed I ripped my shirt
off did you feel disgusted scared
disgusted or scared confused